- We need to break up.
- You said you wouldn't judge me!
- Not really break up.
We need to pretend to break up
in order for you to win the election.
Right now you and Astrid are
splitting the sympathy vote.
I am going to confess
that I cheated on you.
It'll be a scandal.
You will dump me and everyone
will feel sorry for you.
I've cleared it with McAfee and James,
they think it could gain
you six to nine points
depending on how magnanimous
you are about the whole thing.
- But everyone will hate you.
- I love you.
This is what love looks like, Payton.
This is what sacrifice looks like.
This is what it takes to change the world.
I am your first lady,
today and always.
But there are rules.
- Rules?
- We will break up
long enough for you to win
and for no one to suspect
duplicity on our parts,
you will post photos of Big Sur,
the truffle french fries at
Hoagies Diner on route 14,
and cute dogs on your Instagram
at least once a day
with captions like,
"Wish I was here,"
and "Yummy,"
and heart emoji.
When you do so,
I will know you are thinking of me.
- A secret code, I love it.
- And most importantly,
when you pass me in the hall,
you will not pay me any mind
but as soon as we're past each other,
you will turn
and look back.
I need you to do this for me
or I won't be able to survive.
Do you agree to these terms?
- You are the best thing
that will ever happen to me.
Yes.
I agree.
- Let's move on to fish course.
(gong chimes)
I don't wanna say I'm
overwhelmed with shame,
that's too calculating.
It sounds fake.
- It is fake.
- No.
(key clicks)
"I broke up with Payton tonight.
"I guess you could say I cheated on him,
"though it's more complicated than that.
"I will not name the other
party involved at this time
"out of respect to their family," period.
- That's good.
Mysterious, really makes you lean in.
- Post it.
(suspenseful music)
(key clicks)
(computer chimes)
- This is good.
- Jesus, people are freaking animals.
These comments are brutal.
- [James] This is really good.
(computer chimes)
(suspenseful music)
(phone vibrates)
- Hi.
I didn't like doing that.
- I know, it's the right thing to do.
(suspenseful music)
- Hey, Payton.
We're ready when you are buddy.
- Okay.
(key clicks)
(computer chimes)
(melancholy music)
♪ I was raging ♪
♪ It was late ♪
♪ In the world my demons cultivate ♪
♪ I felt the strangest emotion ♪
♪ But it wasn't hate, for once ♪
♪ Yes I'm changing ♪
♪ Yes I'm gone ♪
- Payton.
Hey kiddo.
Look I know you've been
struggling with Mandarin
and River was tutoring you.
You must be going through a lot right now.
- Yeah, I am.
- Just show up for the exams
and I'll give you an A, okay?
- Thank you.
- Okay.
♪ Can't you see ♪
- Hey man, I'm really sorry.
Numbers look great, this was genius.
I wish I thought of it.
Go to the cafeteria and press the flesh.
♪ And I was searching endlessly ♪
♪ But baby now there's nothing left ♪
♪ That I can do ♪
♪ So don't be blue ♪
♪ There is another future ♪
♪ Waiting there for you ♪
♪ It's calling out for you ♪
♪ Arise and walk, come through ♪
♪ Someone beyond that door ♪
♪ Is calling out for you ♪